hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast novel solutions for unbiased
results and metagenomic analysis of
human microbiome samples presented by
matt fostering scientists BRC product
development kyochon and Dominic O'Neil
director microbiome product development
coyote I'm Alexis Krause of laberd's and
I will be our moderator for today's
event we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
laberd's and sponsored by kyochon for
more information about our sponsor
please visit www.dent.umich.edu/license
I am L
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the ask
a question box to let us know that
you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your credit
please join me in welcoming Matt Foss
Frank and Dominic O'Neill I will now
turn the presentation over to them
hello everyone my name is Dominic
O'Neill I'm very pleased to give the
presentation today on Teijin solutions
for unbiased results and metagenomic
analysis of human microbiome samples
before we start just a quick disclaimer
that the products that we're talking
about in this presentation are all
intended for molecular biology
applications and they're not intended
for the diagnosis prevention or
treatment of disease so our agenda for
today is to talk about the microbiome
and sample preparation with a particular
focus on 16s sequencing so I will start
talking about microbiome sample
preparation a little bit about market
biome itself and then talk about our
current best solution for stool DNA
isolation so that you can get good
results for downstream sequencing
at that point at the agenda point three
masked hot springs will take over and
he'll talk about 16s sequencing and
chitin solutions to solve and specific
challenges around NGS sequencing of the
16s gene and he'll end up with a
discussion of cool saliva microbiome
study that we did in house
alright so starting off with microbiome
sample preparation it makes sense to
start with a definition of our terms and
so what does the microbiome mean we're
all familiar with the term by now I
believe but just to clarify microbiome
is the defined as the collective genomes
of the microbes that are in or on the
human body and so there can be different
micro biomes that can be a stool
microbiome that can be a skin microbiome
and the that microbiome is the genomes
of all those organisms that live on that
site the microbiota refers to the
organisms themselves that inhibit
inhabit that environment and then meta
genomics is what we do when we're trying
to study those collectives you know in
genomes and so the microbiome has become
a hugely interesting field of study and
human microbiome project was one of the
first to really catalogue which
organisms live on the human body and the
results of those studies suggest that we
have many many thousands of organisms
that live with us and that essentially
all of those organisms together provide
a second genome the the genes present in
the microbiota outnumber our own genes
by at least 150 to one and the
byproducts of those genes have pretty
serious implications and things like our
metabolism our health creation of
disease and so on
and so by looking at which microbiota
are present in different sites we're
able to determine that different body
sites have unique communities and that
race age gender weight ethnicity diet
various other things all have an effect
on the composition of your microbiome
and then in turn the composition of your
microbiome has an effect on human
metabolism and health
and so it's an incredibly interesting
method of understanding a level of
information about human biology that
hasn't been really looked at before the
last couple of years and it all starts
with looking at the microbiome sample
and if you're going to be doing a
microbiome study you're really looking
at one of three analytes either DNA RNA
or protein and depending on what you're
looking at you're really answering some
slightly different questions so if you
look down at the bottom there's two
major questions that we're trying to
answer when we do microbiome studies and
the first is which organisms are present
and what are their relative abundances
and we can do that really by doing DNA
sequencing so you can either do it by
doing the whole genome shotgun
sequencing and figuring out all of the
organisms that are there if we're also
looking at things like fungus yeasts
viruses that's actually the only way to
get most of those but one that is a very
attractive method is 16s ribosomal RNA
gene sequencing that gives you bacterial
and archaeal some sequences and by
sequencing a relatively small portion of
the genome but one that has the power to
distinguish different bacterial species
from one another you can get a very
broad overview across many samples
without using too much expensive
sequencing and it'll tell you which
organisms are present in the sample that
you're looking at and then you can take
that data and pick it apart and look at
see which organisms may be beneficial in
which are harmful when you look at RNA
and you look at proteins you're looking
at more what are the functions of the
community there which genes are being
expressed which proteins are present and
that's a little bit outside the scope of
this presentation right now we're
focusing on the left side of that branch
of the tree which is looking at DNA
extraction and 16s ribosomal RNA gene
sequencing it's still the most cost
effective way of doing microbiome sample
analysis
and so Kaizen has put a lot of effort
into putting together a workflow for
going from sample to insight on the
microbiome and so the gaijin sample to
insight workflow starts with sample
disruption looking at the the new kit
that we're going to be talking about
today is the kaya empower fecal Pro DNA
kit this is a second-generation version
of the power fecal kit that was
originally developed by mobile and now
further developed by kaya gen and that
focuses on two major problems of
microbiome sample analysis which I'll
talk about in a couple of slides which
is the sample Deborah disruption and
sample preparation and way so we solved
those two issues and then the library
preparation is the next key point that
needs to be taken care of and that's
handled by the kaya seek 16s and IPS
panels that Matt will discuss later on
in this case we've been doing our
sequencing on Illumina platforms and we
can do our data analysis with a CLC bio
microbial genomics pro suite which gives
a very easy high-performance way of
analyzing texana Me's and biological
functions which is pretty easy even for
non bioinformaticians to use
um so the reason why sample preparation
is such a critical point for microbiome
studies is that the the sample when you
start at the beginning the sample prep
will affect everything that you do
downstream so if you don't have an
effective sample prep you're not going
to get a good 16s sequencing calls
and/or quality of data and you'll be
missing some of the critical data that's
present in your sample and so the the
factors that can affect the final data
quality are things like not homogenizing
your sample sufficiently not licensed
Elle's sufficiently and that's
particularly a problem for microbiome
samples where you can have some very
difficult to live samples you could have
spores you can have the various gram
positive bacteria that will not break
open through the sort of standardized
chemical lysis methods and so if you
don't correctly choose your method to do
your lysis then you're going to
influence you're going to bias your
downstream analysis towards easily
disrupted bacteria and then of course
the common DNA isolation issue is that
if you don't have a pure sample at the
end then you're going to have problems
with your various down streams the
nucleic acid quality itself will affect
how well you're able to analyze it but
because one of the most important
microbiome samples our gut sample stool
samples we also have the problem that
there are a lot of substances coming
from the sample that are not DNA but
which will potentially cause problems
for your for your prep so you can have
nucleases and praises that are still
present you can also have analytes that
are going to interact with the various
cellular components and prevent you from
purifying your DNA you can precipitate
your DNA because you didn't get rid of
some of the proteins that are present or
bioactive compounds that are present in
your sample and then they have a
particular problem also
small molecule inhibitors of which stool
has quite a lot and those if not removed
efficiently will purify with your DNA
and then prevent your PCR from giving
you a good unbiased view into the data
so you can you can classify same
Falls a bit across these two factors how
difficult they are to lice and the level
of inhibitors that are present and there
are samples like blood or animal tissue
or cells which are both low and
inhibitor content and are difficult to
lice sorry that are easy to lice and
most of the existing DNA purification
methods will work fine on samples like
that and then you have samples that are
relatively easy to lice but have
particular challenges like FFPE where
you probably have to use a specialized
kit and then you also have some things
which are low in inhibitor content but
difficult to lice potentially like some
difficult bacterial cultures those again
may require somewhat of a specialized
method but are relatively easily solved
and then you have the difficult set of
samples you have things like plant
tissue stool and gut microbes soil
samples biofilms and those are all in
quite difficult to lice without bias and
they're also very high in inhibitor
content which can cause problems for
your downstream and so ty ochen has
invested a lot of effort into solving
the problems of the sample types that
fall into that upper right quadrant the
high inhibitor difficult lysis samples
and that's really what we are focusing
on
with the newly developed kits around the
of kits that we call the power kits so
the power soil the power fecal those are
all designed at very efficient lysis of
microbial samples in difficult matrices
so we do a mechanical homogenous
modernization with tailored lysis
buffers and we can do DNA RNA DNA and
RNA and protein in various different
formats but the combination of
mechanical lysis so that you have an
unbiased bacterial presentation along
with the use of the patent inhibitor
removal technology or IRT which is
present in any of the kaijin kits with
power in its name enables us to get very
clean samples out of these difficult
materials and then we have them
available in various formats since a
microbiome study may involve a handful
of samples that are being tested and can
be used over normal silica spin filters
to people who are using hundreds or even
thousands of samples and require
high-throughput automated applications
and the technology is adaptable for all
of those solutions
so I mentioned a couple slides ago that
the sample derived PCR and our T PCR
inhibitors are a problem and they're a
particular problem in stool things like
bile bilirubin and heme caused
significant problems coming from stool
samples and soil there are things like
humic and fulvic acids and plants that's
mostly polysaccharides and polyphenolics
but when we break open cells to get the
nucleic acids out all of these
inhibitors are also released into
solution and the reason that they are
inhibitors is that they often act quite
a lot like DNA either they bind to DNA
or they bind in similar ways to DNA so
if you don't do something particular
with the sample you're going to end up
purifying these inhibitors along with
your DNA and so you have to set or find
a method that is specialized at removing
these inhibitors from these difficult
samples and there's a lot of different
inhibitors and they can work in
different ways so you can have
inhibitors that work by getting rid of
components that are necessary for your
downstream reactions you know for
example the magnesium chelation the PCR
won't work well if the magnesium isn't
titrated properly and if you have
something that comes from the sample
that is pulling down the magnesium your
PCR will not work as well same thing
with reaction cofactors but then of
course you also have direct interaction
with your nucleic acids either things
that will bind to your enzyme and
displace your nucleic acid things that
will bind to your DNA and prevent the
enzyme from binding to it or things that
may bind directly to the to the enzyme
and inactivate it for some reason
and unfortunately stool is one of the
samples that has a lot of these
inhibitors so if you use a standard
nucleic acid prep you will almost
certainly have very bad downstream
effects and here you can see an example
on this slide of what the inhibitor type
removal technology does on the right
hand side we see two eppendorf tubes on
the left the clear one is when we put
our IRT technology in you can
came out clear and the second one was a
stool sample where we did not use our
IRT and used a standardized DNA
purification technology and you can see
even there are Lu it is brown all of
these inhibitors carried through and as
you can imagine your downstream PCRs are
not going to work well in a sample that
looks like that and our IRT is very
carefully calibrated to get rid of these
samples without harming their DNA i'm
sorry not get rid of the samples to get
rid of the inhibiting substances in your
samples without harming the DNA and it's
incredibly effective
and so we've used that it's been oh it's
well-established already the power soil
and power faecal kits are well-known
there are standardized part of things
like the human microbiome project and
what we have done is created a second
generation of the power soil and how our
fecal cats and so the Chaya empower
fecal Pro DNA kit is currently the gold
standard for removing inhibitors from
stool while getting unbiased microbial
eise's so we've updated the microbial
Isis bead tube from the first generation
the new tube will work significantly
better and also it will be much more
efficient for things like spores and
fungus samples compared to the legacy
kit the inhibitor removal technology is
equally effective that was gold standard
before and it continues to be we remove
basically all of the inhibitors that we
are aware of that can cause problems in
our downstream either PCR qPCR 16s gene
sequencing or metagenomic just shotgun
sequencing and so we know that the
purity of our samples is very very high
and so the second generation of the kits
the power cycle Pro has also been
streamlined from the first version we
have about 18 minutes of total protocol
time to get from from your sample to the
high purity Elliott and here's an
example of what we mean by the improved
yields so this is the the power fecal
Pro DNA kit used on three different
stool samples and compared to a couple
of commercially available kits and you
can see that it vastly outperforms the
competitor kits getting up to twenty
folds higher DNA yields and that's due
to really the the optimized B tube that
we've newly developed as well as
optimized lysis buffer so everything is
soluble as in that first step and once
it's all very thoroughly soluble lies
into solution we can do the bead beading
and crack open all the bacteria that are
present and then move on and the yields
themselves probably don't say too much
on themselves but the next slides will
show that the purity is also very high
so the trick is of course getting both
high yield and high purity at the same
time and so here you can see that we get
excellent yields from the camp our fecal
Pro kit here again on a gel just to
verify again the improvement in yields
on the left hand gel you see the
improvement in yield from fungus from
the legacy power fecal kit to the power
vehicle pro kit that's the lanes one
versus two and then in the gel B that is
the performance of the power fecal kit
in be the legacy kit and C is the power
fecal Pro and you can see vastly
improved DNA yields particularly for
both donor 1 and donor 2 it was a new
kit does a much better job of breaking
open some of the difficult samples
and we mentioned that the the IRT
provides also a significantly better
purity these are these box plots give
you the averages of the two sixty two
thirty and two sixty to eighty ratios of
the stool samples prepped across these
different kits and on the far right and
number three is the new power cycle Pro
kit you can see that our two sixty to
eighty is right around 280 with very
small divergence from that ideal point
and our two sixty two thirty has a
little bit more variation but it's run
around two so we have a nice good pure
DNA coming out of our prep and
considerably better than what we're
seeing with competitive kits and of
course that really matters once we
translate it over into sequencing and
then we what we do see is that with our
new kit we do see an improvement in the
alpha diversity that we get out of a
sample so if we take our samples run
them through this newly developed
compare Phaedo Pro Kit we'll get a
better diet bacterial lysis as shown by
the higher yields and then that
translates into detecting additional
species when you do the 16s sequencing
and so we're convinced that this is a
new gold standard for microbiome
analysis from stool and to talk about
the downstream portions of it I will now
hand it over to Matthew Foss spring who
will talk about the 16s sequencing
hi I'm Matthew Voss Frank um Thank You
Dominic for introducing the give
powerful Perot kit so next I'll be
talking about the our new Kai seek 16s
IPS panels um Fortuna sequencing or
next-generation sequencing
so basically on the 16s sequencing
answers a question of who is there you
know complex microbial sample the 16s
ribosomal RNA gene has been classically
used for a taxonomic classification of
both bacteria and archaea um the reason
being is that all bacteria and archaea
contain this conserved tune and also the
16s ribosomal RNA gene has been
extensively sequenced so there are
multiple with sequences for almost every
species that has has been isolated
so these sequences have been um have
been compiled into different databases
which allow for classification
so the databases um most widely used are
ribosomal database project or RDP green
genes and silver so the result of of
sequencing from the 16s from 16s
sequencing is a taxi or or the
equivalent of two species
characterization in the sample so when
you get the taxi in a sample you can do
a relative distribution of a taxi and a
sample from very low resolution to high
resolution and a taxonomic tree so here
is a depiction of the taxonomic tree
from kingdom to species so you can go
from my a very low resolution or broad
picture at the farm level um also
depicted here where there's um a broad
classification or broad characterization
of a sample where you can see afford
poems in this particular sample or you
can look at more higher resolution
either the genus or species level so a
mystic on the right hand side arm is
more higher higher precision or
taxonomic resolution in the same sample
looking at a number of Genesis
um this same approach can be done to
classify or to to identify fungal and is
in a sample using fungal IGS or other
Apollo genetic marker genes
so the reason um the human life core
volume is important this is because as
Dominic mentioned that it's been shown
that a human microbiome has lots of
associations um with health and disease
so there's been a core microbiome that
has been identified that where is
defined by where a core use is shared by
more than 95% of individuals
um this microbial composition can change
throughout life as you age
or with different lifestyle habits or
diet and disease so for example as you
age um in this in this graph you can see
that some of your microbiome changes
where there may be increase in let's say
firmicutes or in obese individuals
individuals will get a increase in form
acute to prunier bacteria ratio
so there are changes in these relative
amount of taxes um at the farm level or
below I has been shown that more
diversity is normally associated with
better health and also a despot
dysbiosis which is defined as a
microbial imbalance has been associated
with disease different disease states um
for example was a such as obesity or
malnutrition
16's marketing can be used to determine
the composition of any microbial
community committee that could be from
different sites within the human
microbiome on different environmental
samples or even on agricultural samples
so here is a depiction
the 16s gene is it's like I said it's a
highly conserved gene um that's in our
bacteria in an all archaea it's
approximately 1.5 KB in length and has
um these conserved regions depicted in
blue and these variable regions depicted
in red so these conserved regions are
where
[Music]
Chalmers targeting the 16's region bind
to and the variable regions are our
sequences that are diverging enough
between different species or genus where
you allows for a classification of a
particular species or genus
um in the lower figure is fungal bungle
ribosomal RNA and in particular the I TS
region so this particular IPS region is
also highly variable and can be used for
classification similar to the 16s gene
the next
the Cossacks 16s IPS panels and how it
sells on general NGS challenges
so when dealing with next-generation
sequencing in 16s ribosomal RNA gene
sequencing there are several challenges
to seek sequencing the 16s ribosomal RNA
gene and fungal IPs so in general single
applicant sequencing causes a reduced
library complexity and then this leads
to poor quality reads where most of the
reads may be thrown out and not
informative on the second challenge is
the selection of the 16s ribosomal RNA
gene region that is most appropriate for
the studying aims and this could be due
to um your sample type or what you're
actually you want to look for and within
that sample
on the third challenge is that high
background noise in your piece your
reagent either either in the master mix
itself or in the water or is
contaminated with microbial DNA the next
challenge is a complex data analysis
that require multiple steps when you use
open source tools
so for the first challenge with a
reduced library complexity
one way to solve this challenge is the
use of Phi X in your NGS Ron however um
at times you have to use a high amount
of Phi X which leads to really wasted
read capacity that could be used towards
your bacterial classification so one way
to get around this is to use phased
primers so what face primers are our
assistance primers that include up to 0
to 11 additional basis at their five
prime ends so if you look at this top
graph um so in each of these each of
these is one position along the let's
say Cyclery I am if you use of phased
primers allows more base diversity and
equal nucleotide balance so that way in
one cycle in your read it's not just one
base that the sequencer is reading but
it's a mixed up basis that this
sequencer is reading so this shift in
nucleotide balance by the face primers
increases based iversity
and what this leads to is an increase in
quality scores which allows for more
sequences to be used in your OTE
clustering and classification instead of
wasting on your sequences on on five
sequence
so um here are the rest
images and comparison between runs using
unfazed primers and phased primers so
and between these two runs both were you
targeting the v3 v4 region and using the
exact same primer and the Zack same
sample type
um in the unphased primers unphased
section on the top or the freshest
fluorescent images for me on my seek
instrument so r1 signifies read one and
cycle one is a very first cycle that the
sequencer requires so here you can see
most of the signal is in the C channel
and what this causes is an uneven based
distribution um within your read um in
your primer reading and throughout the
whole read and this leads to drop in
quality scores so here in this blue asam
line and within the quality distribution
is about 5% of your reads or a very low
quality and then um in the black and red
assign or 25 and 50% of your reads are
also of low quality however if you look
at the phased fluorescent images and
read one and cycle one is a there are
the flirt fluorescent images are more
even with that within the four channels
so within the ACGT is approximately the
same fluorescent intensity
so if you look at the base distribution
in a phased-in read one that's a more
even based distribution or higher based
diversity I'm within the primer region
and throughout the whole read I'm
especially compared to the unfazed run
and then this leads to higher quality
scores so if we compare the quality
distribution and the phase run there's
only a small amount of reads that are
lower equality and majority of them are
our high quality especially compared to
the unfazed ones so this means basically
that more more of your reads are high
quality and will be used for your oth
clustering and classification
so the second challenge
can challenge is um which reason should
our sequence and the answer it depends
on their sample type and what your
resource question is so if your research
question might be what you know what
region has the most diversity or if
you're interested in a particular genus
or species found that would depend on
which region that you sequence
um it's known that it's been known that
different hypervariable regions have
various degrees of classification
precision and then this depends on on
what type of sample also um the primers
that are used for amplifying the 16s
regions even though they're technically
universal they're not actually universal
primers so these primers may have a bias
on for or against certain taxon
so one example is that um the v4 v5
primers amplify most archaic species
however if you look at other primer sets
such as v1 v2 um they amplify either
none or very few RKO species species so
they're biased against that particular
tree of life
um so one way to get around is is to
sequence um
[Music]
pecans that cover the full gene so with
the classic 60s 80's screening panel
does it covers the entire 16s ribosomal
RNA tuned by by splitting up into
different and pecans and also it's
sequences that fungal IPS so the
screening panel contains amplicons that
cover V 1 V 2 V 2 V 3 V 3 V 4 V 4 V 5 V
5 V 7 V 7 V 9 and fungal IPs
we also offer reading panels where you
can select one to three regions under
multiplex and sequence
so as I said um there's no one reason
that is optimal for every study in fact
it's so this is just a sampling of of
different studies that have been done
even as studies that um that look at the
same sample type do not use the same 16s
region so for example if you look at the
human vagina microbiome the B 1 B 2
region has been used to sequence and B 3
B 4 and if you look at the gut
microbiome um B for reasons has been
used also v5 v6 + B 6 b 8 so using these
are different regions in different
studies it's difficult to compare have a
comparison between these different
studies
for um
uh cuz Kaizen offers the screening panel
which allows um D cleansing of all these
different variable regions um and one
sequence in Iran and in in one library
prep so the benefit of using this
screening panel is allows um a more
robust bacterial profiling um when you
compare it to screening only individual
variable reasons so in here the
screening panel was used to sequence a a
mock community from a tsetse so this my
community sample um has known back
bacterial species with known um
bacterial abundance of each species so
after using the screening panel um each
region was analyzed and you can see that
you can see at least for this one
particular species um stuck to calculus
mutants that V 1 V 2 V 2 B 3 B 3 B 4 and
B 4 B 5 could not classify on
streptococcus mutans
at the species level however the primers
were able to amplify this particular
species as soon by the observed genus
level in similar to the expected level
um but however on b5 b7 and b7 b9
regions were able to classify mutants to
the species level I'm showing that it's
better to use more than one region um
for your microbiome 16s studies
um another way to determine which region
is actually the most informative um for
your studies is to determine the
diversity of each region they're here um
a sewage sample with a sequence with a
screening panel and the one fescue file
resent armed demultiplexed and to the
sixth individual i'm variable regions
and alpha diversity as measured by total
number of ot use was measured for each
region so here for this particular suet
sample on b4 b5 and b3 b4 so the highest
diversity and and maybe used for further
studies especially be using in suits
environmental samples
so another way of trying to identify
which region is um most informative is
look at the classification power of each
region so here again um the
classification for each of the variable
reasons which it was determined for the
sewage sample um and the classification
power is determined by the fraction of
taxes that was that was classified at
that particular um at that particular
level of the the taxonomy trees so for
example if we look at the family this
shows the number of sequences that were
classified to the family level um and
just as similar with the genus the
number of OT use that were classified at
the genus level or the species level so
here shows that um B 3 B 4 and B 4 B 5
regions appear to have a high taxonomic
resolution for this particular series
sample um one thing to note is so in at
times on some of these databases that
the 16s sequence may not be complete and
when it's not complete as the N is that
we're missing so the lower
classification in the b1 b2 and b7 b9
may be an artifact because of the
truncated sequences as 16s sequences
that occur in those databases
the third challenge is how a microbial
with DNA on background that may occur um
so if you have low biomass samples which
is tables that have low bacterial
content even trace amounts of bacterial
or fungal DNA within your master mix or
water may bias results the Kaizen has
developed a PCR kit to address this
concern and then this piece your kit is
a critical component of the UM ky6 16s
IPS panels so to test this mask a UCP
master mix from cotton um we the 16s
promise that target bacterial DNA in 18s
primer set target fungal DNA were used
to amplify on MTC sample or no template
control or basically water and also um 2
to 200 GM copies of e.coli or 3 to 300
GM copies of Candida
so both the 16s in IPS 16s and 18s our
primer sequence primers were able to
amplify down to 2 or 3 GM copies however
um no signal can be detected at NTC
showing that both the master mix and the
UCP water are very clean and there's no
or low background noise associated with
um those reagents
so um during library construction
environmental contamination could be
introduced so one way to monitor that is
to use the classic 16s RTS smart control
so with the smart control is the
spacious basically a synthetic DNA that
contains primer binding sites from the
originate from an e coli
and then arm in between the primer
binding sites are our sequences from
Arabic Dobbs's Valley on it um these
sequences replaced the hypervariable 16s
ribosomal RNA sequences um these are
adoptive sequences cannot be classified
as bacterial or fungal so therefore any
sequences that are classified using the
smart control is due to environmental
contamination um that was introduced
during library construction and using
this control you can monitor both your
library construction and also a month
monitor any environmental contamination
that may be introduced
so the workflow for the Chi 669 IPS
panels is pretty straightforward
the first you start with their sample
extraction I'm using tip format specific
for your sample type next is to perform
a 16s or IPs PCR every I'm doing the
screening panel
this requires to set up three PCR
reactions if you're doing a PCR training
panel then you will pull those three PCR
reactions through two rounds at be clean
up then set up a simple unless PCR then
after that PCR do a one round of kasi be
cleanup arm followed by library QC pull
the libraries and sequence and after you
do the sequence arm do data analysis if
you do the screening panel you will have
to do amplicon demultiplexing
so one way of doing um data analysis is
using our cousin's SCLC microbial
genomics module um this module allows
data to describe discovery of workflow
is basically integrated analytics um and
ah is all the analytics for microbial
genomics and any genomics and um it's
very streamlined workflow um which
allows you did not worry about stringing
together on scripts from open source
software but just allows you to analyze
and interpret your data
so the workflow for the Kuragin 16s IPS
panels is basically forced to import the
data and do a QC of the fescue files
within that microbial genomics module
and then if you're doing the on-screen
panel on to do 2d multiplex that one
fescue file into six fescue files for
each of the 16s regions
next you want to add a database um for
either your 16s sequences or your ITF
sequences
this is followed by ot you cluster tu
clustering and classification and then
some type of diversity analysis
so next we performed a interesting lava
microbiome study um the reason we did
this is because um in the latest
literature um there's been shown that
this differences in the oral microbiome
that's associated with diet and
different systemic and conditions such
as obesity also um saliva is 30 is easy
to access and as a non-invasive sample
that can be used to study their oral
microbiome the previous studies that
have sequenced the 16s gene from the
nispom saliva has um targeted only one
region so by targeting and normally
there are different regions between the
different studies so this um presents
challenges when you want to compare the
data across on the different studies
the purse that we took was that we
collected um saliva arm from donors in a
Brownian manner then we use the cayenne
power pickle pro kit um the extracted
bacterial and fungal DNA I the ky6
extremely panel is used to generate
libraries and any arm association
between the saliva microbiome on
diversity and rip BMI or broad food
choices or sorry
so here I'll show that diversity in this
lava microbiome so in this bottom left
panel is um the diversity of all the
different regions so please and in this
particular um simple set beast the v79
region so you has a slightly different
profile at a genus level and can detect
geniuses that are not detectable in the
other regions and also if we look at the
total total named species in there in
the region diversity on graph again v79
appears to have the highest number of
main species that can classify um in the
right hand graph shows the output
diversity as measured by total or to use
and it appears that of V 4 V naught V 4
V 5 region region allows the highest
diversity when compared to the other
regions so it looks like that b4 b5 and
b7 b9 may be the most informative
regions on board saliva
you
so next we looked at the arm the
diversity of
[Music]
versity in relation to BMI so basically
I'm looking at obese individuals
compared to overweight and normal weight
so in each region the obese group had a
lower um diversity as measured by
Shannon and entropy um which shows that
um in obese of slava microbiome there's
less diverse it's a less much less
diverse microbiome compared to the
normal weight group
so next time we took we looked at the v4
v5 region specifically and looked at
that at the phylum level so at the
phylum level there was an increase in
Firmicutes the Proteobacteria ratio
[Music]
and if we look at the differential
abundance between the two groups there
were a number of geniuses that were
either lower in the obese group um
for example that nice area or poor firm
onus um and there were some that were
increased in the obese group such as
actinomycin
lest we looked at the effect of this
association of a slaughter microbiome on
broad few choices or more specifically
an Eastern based diet compared to a
Western based diet so um in this middle
graph son that I sent Shannon entropy
um this is looking at the b7 b9 region
and with this um with this within this
region um actually the b7 actually the
Western based group has a lower
diversity on compared to the Eastern
based group and then at the phylum level
again um the Western based diet um there
was an increase in firming cues to
proteobacteria ratio and if we look at
the differential abundance um there was
a significant increase in viola and I
mega sphere and attempt opium genus in
the Western diet and there was a
decrease in in Hamas less in cat knows
such a fate by Roger in the Western diet
compared to the eastern based die
so in summary of reuse acai seek 16s IPS
panels which examine arm the full 16s
ribosomal on June and we observe
differences between groups based on BMI
or on broad food choices of Western or
Eastern based diets and interestingly
arm the Western based diet group so
similarities to the Eastern to the obese
BMI group in this saliva microbiome
thank you for your attentions and I will
open up to any questions that you may
have
thank you Matt and Dominic for that
informative presentation we will now
start the Q&A portion of the webinar and
address some of the most commonly asked
questions by our viewers if you have any
questions you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left
your presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen
and click the send button our speakers
will follow up with your questions via
email so let's get started our first
question is going to be what is the best
method to perform sample lysis
okay yeah so this is Dominic and clearly
we put a lot of effort into making sure
that the Cayenne powerful Pro kissed is
the one that will provide the the best
method overall due to the bead lysis but
you have you have a choice in how you
perform the bead lysis whether you want
to do is in a high powered bead beater
in which case you'll be able to get it
out more quickly but you can also do it
in something like a vortex adapter where
it may take a little bit more time and
it's just in 10 minutes to get it but
you'll still get a sufficient of a bead
lysis though the protocols are written
such that you know we will define how it
should be done on kaijin instruments for
stuff outside of that it's going to have
to be optimized separately but I think
it's quite straightforward that using a
mechanical lysis seems to be the best
method to get unbiased bacterial
representation
now our next question this one is going
to be for you Matt where did the primer
sequences come from or how are they
designed yes so um all the primer
sequences originate from space it is a
publicly available database for a logos
that target the ribosomal RNA gene um
specifically the v4 v5 and IPS regions
of primers arm originated from our earth
microbiome project which is a well known
primer set so all these primers are
publicly available however some of the
primers have been modified in order to
allow multiplexing of all the primers
within one PCR condition
Dominic let's go back to you what do I
do if my sample is still inhibitory
yeah so I discussed quite a bit about
how the samples can be very inhibitory
and in some cases even despite all of
the the tricks and the techniques that
we use to get rid of our inhibitory
substances you'd still may be the case
that one a particularly difficult sample
causes inhibition later on in those
cases we recommend to actually decrease
the sample amount then you will also end
up decreasing the inhibitory amount for
samples like that what will sometimes
see is actually you'll get an increase
of yield by decreasing the input amount
and for 99% of samples that will resolve
the issue I mean to be fair 95% of
samples won't have any inhibitory
substances remaining after using the one
of the power line of kits and of those
that may still have some inhibitors
present starting with us lightly slyer
slower amount of material helps and then
the last line of resort would be to
dilute your lu8 before going into your
downstream reaction I should also
improve matters and it looks like we
have time for one more question so Matt
this one is for you can I use open
source software to analyze the fast Q
file
you can use open source software such as
chime or mother um
however if with a screening panel since
it contains sequences for all six
variable regions um we do have a de
multiplexing that is freely freely
available almond can be downloaded from
github so we would supply this link arm
within our gene globe on on cousins
website and in the handbook thank you
I would like to once again thank Matt
and Dominic for their presentation I
would also like to be clabber to make
for making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through December of 2018
you will receive an email from laberd
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's event that's all
for now thank you for joining us and we
hope to see you again soon goodbye